DISRESPECT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
LAST NIGHT, WE WERE THE FIRST TO
BRING YOU THIS DISTURBING VIDEO
THAT SENT SHOCK WAVES THROUGH
THE AMERICAN LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY AND BEYOND.
DISGUSTING AND DEPRESSING.
BUT THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
INCIDENT.
THIS IS WHAT EVERYONE HAS TO
UNDERSTAND.
THIS IS JUST THE LATEST IN A
LONG LINE OF EXAMPLES THAT
DEMONSTRATES A GROWING
DISRESPECT FOR THE PEOPLE AND
PRINCIPLES THAT MOST AMERICANS
STILL HOLD DEAR.
SINCE WE SHOWED YOU THAT AWFUL
VIDEO LAST NIGHT, ANOTHER
SHOCKING INCIDENT SERVICED FROM
HARLEM, AS OFFICERS THEY ARE
TEMPTED TO MAKE AN ARREST.
>> OH!
>> Laura: THEIR REACTIONS TO
THESE KINDS OF ATTACKS WAS
FEARS, AS YOU HEARD RIGHT HERE
ON "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
>> IT MAKES ME SICK.
>> TO OUR FRIENDS IN NEW YORK,
IF YOU DON'T TAKE CARE OF YOUR
COPS, SHAME ON YOU.
>> IT WOULDN'T HAPPEN IF WE
DIDN'T HAVE A PROGRESSIVE,
RETRO- GRESSIVE MAYOR IN
NEW YORK CITY WHO IS DESTROYING
THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
HE'S A DISGRACE.
>> Laura: SOME IN THE
COMMUNITY WERE STILL WILLING TO
DOWNPLAY IT.
>> IT SEEMED LIKE THE OFFICERS
ARE OKAY WITH A LITTLE WATER,
LITTLE STREET FUN.
PEOPLE HAD WATER BALLOONS AND
THEY WERE DOUSING EACH OTHER.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON.
>> Laura: UNBELIEVABLE.
JUST LIKE THERE WERE SOME FOLKS
WHO DIDN'T BAT AN EYE HEARING
THINGS LIKE THIS.
>> [CHANTING]
>> PIGS IN A BLANKET.
>> Laura: THAT WAS DURING THE
OBAMA YEARS.
THE DISRESPECT OF THE POLICE HAS
BEEN BUILDING SINCE THE HEIGHT
OF THE ANTI-VIETNAM WAR
MOVEMENT.
IT WAS DURING THE CHAOS OUTSIDE
1968 DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION IN
CHICAGO WHEN PROTESTERS BEGAN
USING THE TERM PIG TO DESCRIBE
POLICE OFFICERS.
>> THE YOUTH INTERNATIONAL PART
PARTY, THEY CONVERGED ON
CHICAGO.
THEY SAID THEY WERE THERE TO
PROTEST THE WAR, POVERTY,
RACISM, AND OTHER SOCIAL ILLS.
SOME OF THEM WERE ALSO
DETERMINED TO PROVOKE A
CONFRONTATION.
>> Laura: WELCOME OF COURSE
THE DISRESPECT OF OUR MILITARY
VETS FOLLOWED WHEN THEY RETURN
FROM OVERSEAS.
>> WE DID WHAT WE WERE ASKED TO
DO.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T LIKE IT.
THERE WAS A LOT OF FLAK ABOUT
IT.
WHEN WE CAME BACK, WE WERE SPIT
ON AND CALLED BABY KILLERS.
WE DID WHAT WE FELT WE NEEDED TO
DO FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: GOD BLESS HIM.
PRESIDENT REAGAN BROUGHT US
MORNING IN AMERICA AND HE HELPED
INSPIRE A NEW GENERATION OF
YOUNG PATRIOTS WHO WERE EAGER TO
TURN THE PAGE ON THAT
UNFORTUNATE CHAPTER.
OF COURSE THAT DIDN'T STOP THE
LEFT.
THEY HAD ALREADY BURROWED INTO
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES,
SPREADING THE VIEW THAT REAGAN
WAS JUST A WARMONGER AND AMERICA
WAS IN EVIL IMPERIALIST FORCE.
ALL THE WHILE, THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY WAS DOING ITS PART
SLOWLY BUT SURELY RIDICULING AND
DEMONIZING AND DISRESPECTING
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS AND THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY.
THE DISRESPECT REACHED EVERY
ASPECT OF POPULAR CULTURE, AS
FILMMAKERS AND PRODUCERS PRETTY
MUCH RIDICULED EVERYTHING ABOUT
TRADITIONAL AMERICAN VALUES AND
REPLACE THEM WITH SOMETHING MORE
PROGRESSIVE OR TOO MANY OF US,
OR REGRESSIVE.
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SCHOOL BEGAN
TO DISRESPECT AMERICA'S FOUNDING
BY TEACHING A WATERED-DOWN
VERSION OF HISTORY APPROVED BY
THE POLITICALLY CORRECT SENSORS.
THE STUDY OF GREAT BOOKS BY OLD
WHITE RACIST MEN, THAT WAS HELD.
AND THE RADICAL PEOPLE'S HISTORY
OF THE UNITED STATES WAS IN.
SO AFTER ALL THESE YEARS LATER,
SHOULDN'T REALLY COME AS A
SURPRISE WHEN FOUR FRESHMEN
CONGRESSWOMEN EQUATE THE CRISIS
OF THE BORDER TO ONE OF
HISTORY'S GREATEST ATROCITIES?
>> THE UNITED STATES IS RUNNING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, AT
THE BORDER WITH YOU, COMPARING
THE FACILITIES TO A
CONCENTRATION CAMP.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT
COMPARISON?
STICKER ABSOLUTELY.
>> THERE ARE CAMPS AND PEOPLE
ARE BEING CONCENTRATED.
VERY SIMPLE.
>> Laura: THIS JUST ISN'T A
GARDEN-VARIETY CASE OF
HISTORICAL ILLITERACY.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN A DISRESPECT OF
ART.
HISTORY ITSELF TOO IN A FULL
SWEEP AS STATUES AND MARKERS THE
PEOPLE HAD WALKED BY AND DRIVEN
BY FOR DECADES BEING RIPPED DOWN
BECAUSE SOMEONE SOMEWHERE CALLED
THEM OFFENSIVE.
EVEN THE AMERICAN FLAG IS
DISRESPECTED, A REPRIEVE FROM
THE 1960s, AND THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM WHICH WILL ONE
STOOD FOR, IS NOW POINT ITSELF
OF CONTROVERSY.
SIT IT OUT AND YOUR HERO.
QUESTION THE KNEELERS AND YOU'RE
A VILLAIN.
IF WE DON'T RESPECT OURSELVES,
OUR TRADITIONS, AND OUR HISTORY,
WE CAME TO EXPECT OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE OR FRANKLY VISITORS TO
OUR COUNTRY TO RESPECT THEM
EITHER.
>> YOU KNOW THIS IS A MEMORIAL
FOR THE SOLDIERS, RIGHT?
DO YOU SPEAK ENGLISH?
IT'S A MEMORIAL FOR THE
SOLDIERS.
IT'S NOT FOR SWIMMING.
>> Laura: THAT WAS ACTUALLY AT
THE WORLD WAR II MEMORIAL HERE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
A YEAR OR SO AGO, PEOPLE
SWIMMING, NOT REALLY KNOWING
WHAT IT IS, TREATING IT LIKE IT
AT THE BEACH, COMMEMORATING OF
COURSE ALL THOSE WHO SACRIFICE
FOR OUR LIBERTY IN WORLD WAR II.
UNBELIEVABLE.
ALSO LET'S FACE IT.
MANY DON'T RESPECT THE NEED TO
PROTECT INNOCENT LIFE.
UNBORN OR EVEN AFTER THEY'RE
BORN.
>> THE BILL IS PASSED.
>> Laura: AND WE DON'T RESPECT
EACH OTHER.
EVEN IN FRONT OF CHILDREN AND
ONLOOKERS.
>> [SHOUTING]
>> Laura: TOO MANY DON'T
RESPECT THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
I.C.E. OR THE BORDER PATROL,
MANY OF WHOM ARE HISPANIC, BY
THE WAY.
ALSO IN UNIFORM, 99.5% OF THEM
DOING THEIR BEST UNDER EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES.
>> I THINK ABOLISH I.C.E. IS A
CALL TO ACTION ON SEVERAL
LEVELS.
>> NEED TO ABOLISH I.C.E. AND
END ALL INHUMANE DEPORTATION
PROGRAMS.
>> ABOLISHING I.C.E. PROTECT MY
FAMILY FROM THE MILITARIZATION
OF ITS HAPPENING IN
NEIGHBORHOODS.
>> Laura: THIS INTO THE WORDS
OF DISRESPECT.
THIS ISN'T MINOR CRITICISM OF
THE GOVERNMENT OR EVEN VIGOROUS
CRITICISM OF THE GOVERNMENT.
IT'S A WHOLESALE EFFORT TO BURN
IT DOWN.
AND LORD KNOWS THAT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA WE DON'T RESPECT
EACH OTHER AT ALL.
DEMOCRATS AND WE REPUBLICANS CAN
ALL DO BETTER.
BUT BACK TO HOW WE STARTED, HOW
WE TREAT THE MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM.
MANY BLACK AMERICANS BELIEVE
THAT THEY ARE UNFAIRLY TARGETED
BY POLICE AND MANY POLICE
OFFICERS BELIEVES THEY ARE
UNFAIRLY TARGETED TOO.
THEY ARE JUST TRYING TO DO THEIR
JOBS.
AND THIS IS HOW THINGS END UP.
YOUNG MEN SITTING IN A CAR
LAUGHING AT WHAT THEY THINK IS
THE HUMILIATION OF POLICE
OFFICERS WHO ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY COULD, THEIR
JOBS, KNOWING THEY'LL POST THE
VIDEO, YOU BET.
IT WILL GET THEM A LOT OF LIKES
AND MAYBE SOME MORE YUKS.
NO WONDER SO MANY CITIES ARE
HAVING TROUBLE RECRUITING POLICE
TODAY.
WOULD YOU SUBJECT YOURSELF TO
THIS ABUSE DAY IN AND DAY OUT?
PERHAPS IT WAS MIKE HUCKABEE
LAST NIGHT WHO SAID IT BEST.
>> AND THERE'S A CRIME IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, CALL ON SOMEBODY